now I hear you're a master of
Impressions no I'm not I honestly do
terrible Impressions I just I just
commit to
them I just but if you up for it I would
I I want I would want to you know play a
little game with you man is that cool
man I give you somebody you can give
me I'm not I'm telling you I ain't no
Frank cendo out here dude I'm not like
I'm terrible at it but let's
see all right okay what would grank say
about Travis Kelsey and Taylor
Swift yo
Jules can you
believe that Kelsey and Swift are
together like I I just that's pretty
cool like something like that that's
that's kind of what I can't believe all
okay
what what would Bill what would Bill
bich say if you sent him a birthday
present
if I sent him a birthday
yeah he probably wouldn't say anything
but he would he would probably write you
a crazy he write he he writes you
handwritten letters and he'd be very
thoughtful on it but he be like look
Jules
like I hope you don't think that I'm
going to get you a present now like what
the
what would what would Tom Brady say
if you invite him on a
vacation
if I invited him on a
vacation yeah look babe you know like
babe I I got my kids in in Miami in New
York babe I I'm probably not gonna be
able to make it babe sorry babe I love
you babe next time we go to Bakers I'll
I'll bring you I'll I'll helicopter you
there so thanks for the invitation but
I'll let you
know hey yeah you got his voice down
perfect what what would what would Randy
say if someone just got
Moss edel nut you know that song a
star was born today yep they made that
that that song was made when I was born
and now they saying this about
me 98 first round get to know
me they used to tell me that all the
time edut 98 first round get to know me
Randy you're the greatest receiver I've
ever seen I Know Who You Are
98 first round okay okay what what would
Von Miller say after seconding Tom
Brady what would what would Von
Miller yeah what would I
say yo Brady you can call me Vonnie I
only let the ladies call it to me
usually but I love you
man hey man that hey that was perfect
bro like you said bro you're a master
bro you're a master of absolutely I'm
terrible at
Impressions man I love to be Bell TR and
the Randy M went man like you are great
man